hola buenas tardes pues estamos a unos
metros de lo que es la gran fiesta de la
celebración del matrimonio igualitario
en chile- cuentas de personas han
llegado hasta aquí y siguen llegando
ataviados con la bandera multicolor para
celebrar que el matrimonio igualitario
es ya casi una ley primero tiene que ser
promulgada por el presidente sebastián
piñera como se señalaba a partir de ahí
debe ser publicada en el diario oficial
de la república de chile y transcurrido
ese plazo 90 días después las personas
podrán contraer matrimonio las personas
de diversa identidad sexual podrán
casarse con los mismos derechos que el
resto de las personas aproximadamente
podremos ver los primeros matrimonios
cuando comience el próximo gobierno de
chile marzo abril del próximo año y el
pacto tiene esta decisión patricia en un
país dominado desde hace décadas por
políticas conservadoras
por lo que hemos observado
tanto en el congreso donde los senadores
y los diputados se impusieron de una
forma mayoritaria a favor de esta ley
que hace de chile una mejor sociedad una
sociedad más digna para todos donde hay
más igualdad es que la gente en la calle
en general está muy a favor del
matrimonio igualitario apenas ha habido
como reacción esta persona en las redes
sociales y es algo que la mayoría de los
chilenos estaban a favor desde hace
tiempo así que podemos decir que las
fuerzas conservadoras todavía residen
más en el congreso que en la calle por
lo menos en lo referido a este tema
brevemente ha habido alguna reacción de
los dos candidatos presidenciales que
estarán en la segunda vuelta del 19 de
diciembre
como sabemos pues indian es opuestas
mientras que el candidato josé antonio
kast y porque el matrimonial es ser
entre un hombre y una mujer y reiteró
esta postura en el día de hoy el
candidato boric se muestra a favor de
este matrimonio igualitario que hace de
este chile un lugar más digno más
igualitario y mejor para todos hoy